it's no secret that people are crazy
about eggs
we can't seem to stop eating them
in july 2018 the u.s produced more than
7.9 billion eggs for consumption
that's more eggs than there are people
on the planet
but shopping for eggs can be a little
confusing
what do all these different labels mean
are brown eggs different than white eggs
which eggs are the best deal for your
money which are the most humane and
finally are eggs good for you
this
is the conscious consumer's guide to
eggs
let's start with sizes the five primary
sizes of eggs you're likely to see in
the grocery store are small medium large
extra large and jumbo these sizes are
set under guidelines by the usda and
they're determined by weight per dozen
you can expect a small carton to weigh
about 18 ounces medium 21 ounces large
24 ounces extra large 27 ounces and
jumbo 30 ounces these weight classes
take into account the weight of the
entire carton not necessarily the
individual eggs so don't be surprised if
you find a small egg in your jumbo
carton
like snowflakes all eggs are unique and
special
you may have noticed that some egg
cartons in the store are issued grades
not all curtains will have these grades
aren't mandatory and any companies who
get their eggs graded actually pay the
usda for this service the eggs can be
categorized into three grades grade a a
a and b the grades are determined by the
quality of the whites and yolks as well
as what the outer shell looks like us
grade a a is the highest of the three
grades and it's given to eggs that have
thick whites nice round yolks and
unblemished shells grade a a is best if
you're frying or poaching an egg really
it's good for any dish where appearance
is very important
u.s grade a eggs which you'll typically
find at the grocery store are pretty
similar to grade a a eggs the only real
difference is that they have reasonably
firm whites as opposed to very firm
whites the whites of eggs categorized as
us grade b tend to be thinner and the
yolks may not be perfectly round and
while the shells won't be broken they
might not look perfect either grade b
eggs are typically used to make liquid
or dried egg products
as of 2017 about 84 of hens that lay
eggs in the u.s live in battery cages
densely packed cages that don't give
hens any chance to really roam outside
about 16 percent of egg laying hens in
the u.s are cage-free hens which means
the hens live in indoor houses and are
free to roam both vertically and
horizontally the usda's definition of
cage-free also requires that the
chickens have access to fresh food and
water
the usda's definition of free range
means that hens must not only be able to
roam both vertically and horizontally
but they must also be given free access
to the outdoors while they're producing
eggs this outdoor area is allowed to be
fenced in and must keep the chickens
safe from predators
both cage-free and free-range eggs are
grouped together in statistics
additionally there are a few labels used
for eggs that are actually issued
through non-profits three big ones you
might have seen are american humane
certified certified humane and animal
welfare approved now these labels don't
follow any set meaning from the
government and companies pay to have
these labels added to their products
most chicken eggs are either brown or
white
some can even be bluish green it's all
based on the hen's breed for example
like horn chickens tend to lay white
colored eggs whereas plymouth rock
chickens tend to lay brown colored eggs
it's just a matter of what pigments the
hen produces so is there a nutritional
difference between colors not really
nutritionally speaking eggs are very
similar regardless of color one factor
that can impact the nutritional makeup
of an egg the hand's environment a 2014
study published in the journal nutrition
found that eggs produced from free-range
hens have three to four times the amount
of vitamin d compared to cage raised
hands that are kept indoors and although
there isn't much of a nutritional
difference between brown and white eggs
brown eggs tend to be a little more
expensive what gives
the hens that lay brown eggs tend to be
larger and according to usda research
food technologist deanna jones they need
more nutrients in their bodies to
produce the pigments so more feed more
color more expensive
but what about yolks
the color of an egg yolk is primarily
determined by the hen's diet certain
plants or additives used in chicken feed
contain yellow orange pigments called
xanthophylls when ingested by a hen
these pigments give the yolk a rich
yellow color some producers even add
marigold petals carrots or other
additives to their feed to give their
hands eggs a rich yellow-orange color
hens that are fed a wheat and barley
diet on the other hand tend to produce a
paler color yolk white cornmeal diets
can even result in a yolk that's
virtually devoid of color
so now that we know all of that one
polarizing question remains are eggs
good for you
it's been the subject of heated debate
since the late 1970s around that time
doctors began realizing that cholesterol
you know that fatty substance that's
important for digestion and cell
function can put us at risk for heart
disease when consumed in excess a lot
decided then that high cholesterol foods
like butter red meat and yes even eggs
should be avoided
[Music]
and while consuming cholesterol can
increase levels of it in the blood a
growing number of studies according to
npr have shown that most of the
cholesterol in our bodies is heavily
influenced by things like genetics
gender age and overeating things like
trans fats and sugars
dr walter willett a harvard medical
school professor has studied thousands
of patients and hasn't found evidence
that a moderate level of egg consumption
increases one's risk for heart disease
except for those already at risk due to
genetics
at the end of the day there's no black
and white answer
as willett told npr it is hard to say
that eggs are good or bad in terms of
health they seem to be in the middle
somewhere
[Music]
[Music]
you